it's very large either bigger ones but
it's a nice big number yep a particular
number it's a number I had some Mon
Association would rank might you say
December is the 129 decimal digits long
so it's probably more than your
calculator can handle easily about
Maeby's days calculators are getting
pretty smart but it's something a
computer could work with easily and if
as computers have and have might have
good reasons to work with them this
super has a history that goes back to
the late 70s we created this number at
the challenge I don't remember the
number I haven't memorized it so if
you'd like I can read you a few than
digits so one one four three eight one
six two five seven five seven eight
eight eight eight that's four eight in a
row six seven six six nine two three
five seven seven nine nine seven six one
four six six one two zero 102 189 and
that's the first line out of the day and
it goes on for a while and it ends
8 7 9 5 4 3 5 4 1
so 129 digits all to go all together we
didn't read them all but yeah I can
they're posted on my website if you want
to see them be in the description of the
video the number has a name as well so
it's got a much shorter name than the
number itself sometimes called RSA 129
because it has 129 digits are necessary
those are the initials of three of us
that worked on an interesting
cryptographic system back in the 70s our
my first refreshness or my last name
SSID Cheniere and a is for land Adelman
and the three of us invented a
particular cryptographic system that's
based on big numbers like the one you
just heard so where did this number come
from this number we created as part of
an experiment the challenge to find out
more about the security of the
cryptographic scheme that we proposed
the scheme that we proposed was based on
products of large prime numbers so this
number has an interesting property it's
the product of a large prime number P
and another large fun member q and you
multiply those two prime numbers
together and you get this number RSA 129
so that's why was created and we created
it secretly choosing P secretly choosing
Q in fact we forgot how we created P and
how we created Q nobody
no not even us actually after the number
was created what those numbers P and Q
were they were multiplied together
they're uniquely determined by the
product there's only one p 1q that
multiplied together to give this number
but the security of the cryptographic
scheme that we proposed depends on
assumptions like that that nobody should
be able to find out a P and a queue from
the product P times Q we generated the
number of you looking at yes audience
Len and I did that we drew Jenna the
number of revolts of dice we generated
some random numbers when we multiplied
on some prime numbers that were near the
initial numbers we generated and then
multiplied them together so we generated
them maybe in my subconscious some words
there I don't feel like I doubt it
can you get to write them down a scrap
of paper we didn't write them down now
so why did you keep them in safe with
something so I can use the answer to the
puzzle well if the puzzle gets solved
then we will find out the P and the Q
and if the puzzle didn't get solved all
that that's fine I risk having it to get
stolen or something if somebody broke
into my wall whatever I would keep those
numbers finding a prime numbers it's not
that hard actually I mean you just need
to find big numbers and finding big
numbers that hurt big random numbers I'm
so hard you can roll some dice order you
know use other methods and so we gave
some some big rant big random numbers
and then you can see is that number
prime well maybe not maybe it's even so
it's obviously not prime so if you can
add 1 to it and take that numbers Prime
and there's an easy test for primarily
which I don't need to go into here but
it's easy to test up a numbers Prime and
so you can just search a little bit and
Prime's are actually quite common so it
doesn't take much time to find out large
prime number and then you got your
number P and you can do the same thing
started with a different starting point
to find your number Q and you got a big
prime number P a big 9 primary cube RSA
was a response to an open problem posted
by diffie-hellman diffie-hellman has
this idea that you could have a way of
doing cryptography called public key
cryptography where you could tell
somebody how to encrypt without telling
them how to decrypt so the idea of RSA
is that the core difficulty that you
give an adversary is the product of
factoring a large number and so you
might choose to large prime numbers
multiply them together and post that as
your public key so ok so I'm sending a
message to you using your public key
you've got four posters you're publicly
privately to contractors you do yourself
need to know those two prime factors in
order to do the decryption effectively
so you use keep those secret that's your
secret key you don't tell anybody you
need those to decrypt in the case of
this challenge we weren't decrypting
messages sent to us without so we didn't
need to record the factors but it's
practice with RSA you'll need to have
one party in those the prime factors and
everybody else is just the public key
the product of those two prime factors
we came up the idea and it seemed to
work things that have the right kind of
properties if it gave the ability to
post a public key in such a way that
nobody could figure out how to decrypt
something it was encrypted with that
public key but there's a missing piece
then and still now to some extent we
don't really know how hard factoring the
product of two large prime numbers is
and so we set out a challenge and that
was the first channel to actually it was
many more challenges later a whole
ladder and sequence of challenges but
RSA 129 was the first one and we said
you know this we think is a hard problem
we don't think you'll be able to solve
that we put an estimate in a column
issue that Martin Gardner wrote about
this estimating that would take 40
quadrillion years to factor this
particular product RSA 129 and we
offered $100 to anybody could do it
and the goal there was just to learn
about the difficulty of factoring if
somebody could factor it we say well
you're off Rivest engineered Adelman
does the how hard factoring is maybe
it's easier than you thought and so we
offered $100 prize so at the time it was
a open problem and still is no problems
to hardness it was poorly studied at the
time there were some papers published
not like now after after RSA in factory
has become an object of much more
studying but but before before then it
was more of a curiosity and a few people
studied it and so we had to search
around to find people who thought about
factoring but it seemed to be hard there
were no good algorithms it's also the
case that the RSA is flexible in the
sense that you can choose prime numbers
of any length and build an RSA modulus
that way so you can build numbers of
products of 250 digit Prime's or 200
digit crimes or - 200 digit Prime's or
whatever you like so you could make it
much more challenging for the adversary
by choosing the primes large order so
let's seem like factoring would be a
good
Foundation and the question really is
how big should the primes be chosen so
with RSA 129 it sat there for quite
awhile I mean we had that number was
published in the late 70s during the 80s
not much happened computers started
getting faster the internet started
happening in the early 90s the web
happened you know but that number was
just sitting there and seemingly ignored
for a long time but then in 94
a team of researchers came up with the
factorization and they used the
increases in computer speed to factor
the number they use the internet to get
a team of people all over the planet the
factor the number they use better
algorithms to factor the number and
after a lot of work they were able to
produce the two prime factors that when
multiplied together gave Mars a 129 and
that was quite a shock to us what I mean
if everyone's working on the one
specific case I would have thought maybe
it would be easier to crack you know for
all the people were looking at the one
number you can sort of predict the
growth of technology so the speed of
computers you can predict the amount of
the number of computers you can get
together to work on a problem you can
predict pretty well what you don't know
how to predict the level is the better
improvement in algorithms and that's
really what the key was here was better
algorithm did this like undermine
anything or like or where had the
technology had where had cryptography
gone consent cryptography evolved
tremendously since then it was it was a
surprise to us it didn't mean that RSA
was in any way disabled or get it just
meant that numbers of that size
shouldn't be used those numbers were too
short the primes were too short that was
a lesson there and I was one of the
things we wanted to learn from this
challenges is that a reasonable size the
user do you need to use larger numbers
people still use RSA they just use
larger numbers than this now so instead
of a one hundred and twenty nine digit
number they might use a two hundred
decimal digit number or three hundred
days old digit numbers say so larger
numbers seem to be immune from these
kinds of attacks still so we had offers
$100 for the factoring of this and so we
had to pay up and we did so we wrote a
cashier's check for $100 and then gave
it to the team a Derek Atkins Michael
Graff re and lunch our
Leyland was a team that led to as many
other people were involved as well until
we wrote $100 cashier's check for them
at the time I thought it was probably
and maybe still is the cheapest purchase
of lots and lots of computer time ever
so it really $100 for that much
computing time was really quite a coup I
thought of that one gating so if we're
computing this seems to be coming along
at people keep working on it so there's
quite a bit of money involved and the
research side of things I would love to
see it fall flat on its face and not
work at all it would be the demise of
our essay should quantum computing
happen they say you're the bank and you
give out two numbers they're public so
everyone can know them they're not
secret numbers and they secure number
three and the number ten the bank also
has a secret